[Musique]
je regarde avions converti en entrepôt
pour la banque alimentaire
l'espace est immense à l'image des
besoins dans une ville où le taux de
chômage atteint 12%
quand même pour un pic à john mack a
cité avec plus de 400 familles par mois
qui ont besoin d'être pour se nourrir le
directeur daniel woods est débordé
afrique marie la pandémie s'est ajoutée
une situation économique qui se
détériorait depuis 2015 déjà avec la
baisse du prix du pétrole
ici le prix du pétrole décide de tout
quand les grandes compagnies comme sin
crewdson corps ralentissent leurs
activités parce que la demande mondiale
chute c'est toute l'économie qui en
souffrent dans ce contexte les employés
permanents syndic qui je compte plutôt
chanceux 90 des quelque 3600 membres du
nid fort à fort mcmurray ont été mises à
pied 40 sur déjà de retour au travail
mais le président local du syndicat
reconnaît que touche ne sont pas dans
cette situation
l'industrie pétrolière fournit aussi du
travail à bon nombre d'entreprises
contractuels mais cet afflux de
travailleurs venus d'un peu partout au
canada s'est considérablement réduit
résultat toutes les entreprises services
aux dû mettre à pied des employés dans
les beaux jours on était à 178 l'homme
d'affaires jean marc guillemot gervais
hôtels et 122 employés à fortec mairie
si sa saison estivale était sauvé par
l'arrivée de travailleurs de la
construction
après les inondations du printemps
dernier ils se demandent de quoi seront
faits des prochains mois est ce que ça
vaut le coup
regardez en cours tous les hôtels
ouverts cela peut-être il va y avoir un
réalignement là dessus donc une fois de
plus ils ont d'autres mises à pied dans
ce contexte difficile
l'association francophone de la région
confirme que ses services d aide à la
recherche d'emploi sont plus populaires
que jamais mais avec un horizon
économique qui reste sombre
l'heure est à la remise en question chez
certains travailleurs général masse et
il me pose la question est ce que ça
vaut la peine que je reste toujours
hissé mais j'essaye de garder le moral
avec mes clients que c'est juste c'est
passager à forte minorité plusieurs
constate que les choses ont changé mais
dans cette ville qui affrontait des
catastrophes naturelles et des tempêtes
économiques l'espoir de retour des beaux
jours demeure on va continuer à le tenir
le coup parce qu'on est comme un chef
lézignan là dessus c'est un petit peu
notre traitement tout en se préparant au
pire dans son entrepôt d'années de wesh
demeure lui aussi optimiste malgré tout
même si les effets de la pandémie
pourrait se faire sentir encore
longtemps ici mathieu gaye et radio
canada